you can't make an omelet without
breaking a few eggs and you can't become
the number one drama on television
without generating at least a little bit
of off-screen drama that's certainly the
case with NCIS the hit procedural might
be popular now but it wasn't an easy
path what went on behind the scenes to
make this one of the highest-rated shows
on television that's a question worthy
of its own investigation title troubles
few people remember it now
but when NCIS first spun off from parent
show jag in 2003 it was far from a
guaranteed success in fact CBS was
worried that the show would be
overshadowed by the network's runaway
smash CSI
so CBS called the show Navy NCIS for the
first season in order to minimize
confusion over the similar acronyms
showrunner and creator Donald Belisario
eventually came in to the network to
drop the Navy part because it's totally
redundant the N in NCIS already stands
for naval it's a lot to keep track of us
mark Harmon's rage Bellisario abruptly
left NCIS in 2007 for a very unexpected
reason star Mark Harmon forced him out
reportedly the two tangled behind the
scenes for months over Harmons
dissatisfaction with Belisarius chaotic
management style it led to a showdown
and the network decided they could live
without Belisario who was forced to
resign the show continued with the
presumably happy Harmon sitting pretty
Belisario still got the last word
however NCIS lawsuit Angelus given the
huge success of NCIS it seems like a
no-brainer that would eventually spawn a
spinoff but the creation of NCIS Los
Angeles in 2009 actually led to a major
lawsuit that's because NCIS creator
Donald Belisario had a clause in his
contract giving him the right to create
the first spin-off after he was forced
off the show
CBS hired Shane Brennan to create the
offshoot show instead after years of
legal wrestling is settled out of court
for an undisclosed amount at an
estimated net worth of 250 million
dollars Belisario certainly isn't
suffering either way and CIS bred in
2013 NCIS was poised to add yet another
series to its franchise in the form of
NCIS red introduced in a two-episode arc
on NCIS Los Angeles NCIS red was going
to star John Corbett as the leader of
red team an anti-terrorist unit within
and C is one NCIS team
the network decided they didn't really
dig what they saw in the backdoor pilot
and the series was cancelled before it
ever began instead the network launched
NCIS New Orleans Don Johnson almost Mark
Harmon has been the face of NCIS for
well over a decade now but viewers could
have actually seen a very different face
in the role of agent Leroy Gibbs that's
because the role was actually offered to
Don Johnson first and he turned it down
he wasn't the only candidate though
rumor has it that NCIS New Orleans star
Scott Bakula was also on the original
shortlist for agent Gibbs way back in
the day since Belisario and Bakula had
previously worked together on quantum
leap by the time NCIS New Orleans came
along the showrunners knew the right man
for the job was vacuumed uh because he's
spectacular pauley perrette twitter
blunder in 2013 actress cote de pablo
who played fan favorite NCIS agent Ziva
de vivre abruptly announced her
departure from the show it was a
surprise not only to fans but to her
co-stars around the same time her red
posted a tweet of herself wearing a
shirt she received in 2007 which said I
love my job
it seemed innocent enough but it set off
a minor Twitter war with de Pablo's fans
who saw it as an attack allegedly the
Pablo called Perez to ask that she
stopped tweeting about the situation
Barret shut down her feed for less than
a day she should have just won the shirt
his daddy Koretz personal life while
Perron has clearly been a subject of
real-world drama she's done her best to
turn lemons into lemonade by using her
position as a platform for advocacy in
2006 she revealed that her former
husband Francis coyote shivers had
subjected 30 years of physical and
emotional abuse and just in 2015 after
she was randomly attacked by a mentally
ill homeless man she began championing
the rights of the homeless distri really
super great well to be alive but the
other part is that like my heart breaks
for that guy and and it breaks for every
single person that's out there on the
street she's also stood up for marriage
equality and even recorded music with a
positive message for victims of abuse
Diane Neal's Twitter meltdown in 2015
guest-starred Diane Nia launched an
angry Twitter attack on NCIS New Orleans
upset over safety issues she encountered
on set while filming Neil called the
show's production dangerous and stupid
saying stuff like they just used me like
a rented mule
and these folks don't give a damn didn't
go over well behind the scenes Neil
apologized and deleted the tweets some
certified folks on reddit captured the
drama and preserved it for posterity
however moral the story never tweet
angry a very important cameo with three
different shows and more than twenty
combined seasons the NCIS franchise has
had a lot of high-profile guest stars
but none of them can quite match the
star power our First Lady Michelle Obama
who appeared as herself on the series in
early 2016
her appearance was made in support of
joining forces a nationwide initiative
supporting service members veterans and
their families kind of makes that time
Taylor Swift showed up on CSI seemed
pretty lame by comparison thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know what you've heard about
NCIS